president of underlying will lay out the
commission's priorities in the state of
the union debate
meps will quiz her to make sure the eu
is delivering on key challenges
like the economy energy and climate
change
meanwhile meps expect the commission to
keep on working on proposals for eu
reform from the conference on the future
of europe
let's be loyal to the outcome of the
conference
let's implement its conclusions as soon
as possible because it's the will of the
people and let the will of the people
prevail
will continue to support ukraine as meps
vote on further measures to reduce eu
dependence on russian energy and ensure
the green transition
they include new rules on renewables and
energy efficiency greener buildings and
infrastructure for clean vehicles
sooner rather than later we have to cut
ourselves off our toxic dependency of
russian
fossil fuels our work will continue
meps are set to green light a single
charger for digital devices like mobile
phones tablets and headsets
they want to reduce electronic waste and
improve consumers lives
parliaments will vote on the artificial
intelligence act
meps want the eu to be a global leader
in utech for business and public
services while ensuring democratic
rights and freedoms are protected
meps are also set to vote on landmark
workplace legislation to promote gender
equality on company boards and guarantee
fair minimum wages adequate minimum
wages must ensure
a decent standard of living
reduce weight inequalities
and contributes to upward social
convergency
finally in december parliaments will
award the 2022 sacker of price to honor
people who defend human rights and
freedom of thought around the world
[Music]